the search continues for a man who shot
and killed one person and injured
another this happened early Sunday
morning on the Fremont Street Experience
Joe Mohler spoke to the victim's family
he's live near Fremont Street with what
they are saying Joe
well that victim has been identified as
23-year-old Raymond raynova he was shot
and killed early Sunday morning here on
the Fremont Street Experience and now we
have new videos showing the moments
leading up to when shots were fired this
video shows the altercation happening on
Fremont Street outside of binions you
can see how crowded it was and you can
see a group of people fighting and then
a man dressed in black pulls out a gun
and opens fire
Raymond Renova was killed this is a
GoFundMe created for him I spoke to his
family who now is desperate to see the
person responsible arrested I
I never and this guy's walking around
coward you think you did something his
aunt Christy Santa Cruz says reynovo
recently moved to Las Vegas loved art
and was a tattoo artist his sister was
with raynova and another cousin that
morning she says they don't know why the
altercation started Metro said the
shooter was dressed in all black and
they were reviewing security footage a
bystander on Fremont was also shot and
injured
I'm back out here live we also reached
out to the Fremont Street Experience to
see if they had any sort of comment and
they mentioned that they would not be
commenting on the incident that happened
near early Sunday morning now police
continue to look for more information so
if you have anything that could assist
them in this investigation they would
like to hear from you reporting live
near Fremont Street Joe Moeller live
local now